what is happening there reject nation
greg
here i was doing laundry throwing
clothes in the washer and then this
black widow trailer dropped reached
right in that washer
pulled out my marble shirt changed the
laundry room
wasn't a good idea a family walked in
anywho this black widow clip it's called
you got a plan gotta check this trailer
out i do want to plug the gi joe trailer
is supposed to come out tonight too as a
matter of fact
by the time this is uploaded the gi joe
trailer probably dropped so we're gonna
put our trailer reaction for that up but
also
we have an interview with henry golding
snake eyes himself that we're gonna put
into that trailer reaction so be sure to
check that out
anywho let's see what this clip is all
about
really digging the music
ah gotta love a good good stunt man on
bike
[Applause]
okay
stunt woman
cool can't wait
finally getting it
something just just sings in this
trailer that the chemistry
between elena and natasha florence pugh
and scarlett johansson is gonna shine
love the stunt work in this trailer you
know i really quite enjoyed the music in
this trailer it's from the same composer
i want to say lorne
something or another a fact i remember
is that he actually did the music for
the last mission impossible movie i
don't know if he did the other ones but
i know he's doing the next two mission
impossible movies as well considering
how
so much of when i watch like the footage
of black widow i'm
reminded more of the mission impossible
like the film is so much like this
espionage spy thriller but
whenever i see the footage for black
widow i usually go to mission impossible
so to have the composer from that
franchise
come on over here feels appropriate and
yeah the action scenes do look cool i
know like
you know badass female on a bike was not
invented
by the matrix reloaded with trinity ever
since i saw the matrix reloaded
with trinity on a bike anytime i see
that i'm like well i have this like
nostalgia association i don't know how
it's just a subconscious thing that
occurs for me but when i
whenever i see that i'm always so drawn
to it and the action does look great i
think kate shortland the director of
this movie is going to do an awesome job
and yeah the chemistry between the two
you do get a little bit of that like you
know we're coming off falcon and winter
soldier and you get a little bit of that
like falcon wonder soldier vibe a little
bit like cap and bucky but more like
falcon and winter soldier
or new cap and winter soldier but we're
still yet to get
that much details on how florence pew
will do the portrayal
of elena but i like that you're getting
like sort of this like
fun sarcastic sisterly approach with
them
but damn the stunt work there looks
great saying you got a plan and then
thinking about falcone winter soldier
how there was that bit
in the second episode uh that was making
fun of the whole thing with sam wilson
not having a plan or bucky being like
what's our plan
this feeling a little bit like captain
america winter soldier
it's all tying in we're all getting the
reminiscent vibes in the fields to think
this movie was just like
waiting to come out for so long that the
fact that it's actually coming out in
july 9th it's right around the corner
it doesn't feel real to me doesn't feel
real anywho guys what'd you think about
this clip leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
thank you so much for being here keep a
lookout for a reaction for black widow
when it comes out
here on the channel